[Music]
deaf learners don't report on Dolce
behave on so Santa so principality bonds
to de todas o fo fo a mere apprentice
Kosovo pass kosabu grammar school
philosopher clean atmosphere home au
revoir je m'appelle EDTA is
responsibility Jamie socialism
mesosphere is existed upon unison
applaud fun set a structure ahora de de
quoi de Ferreira ensuite Amazon's
especially sedona question do new xico
Musa Moses Isaiah prophesied on ot a
physician declares
genetics a condom la la fecha professor
s kappa le pré messiah men para la ilaha
medulla primaporta la vo costume to t
phenomena which it is to zalem MZ t v--
a design is cotton waffle a croissant
window declare shiva condo Souza
phenomenon travail do kapa haka
[Music]
so no primo Vienna Denver's go as low
poly pomona Palais des Vosges Oporto
neoprene Android CDs application no
question coda Prima oh ho ho no Connor
Lucas refers oh no Coco Luo la pata Sita
por todo dia de su material for sale et
al maja Duncan cetera et voila
and presale Vinod savoir faire le
transmetal Naji Nahas Georgina's Rue de
varville no Castro scoffs embassy kuzuha
paseo de ma vie Oh c'est magnifique in
South LA Dodgers Lupo supremacy Rakuten
devotion travel to manila envelope
alador susan salah vacant also voila due
to Strava ronamoon this my sin order the
preparation cause to celebrate amen
[Music]
the market for culture is huge
unfortunately almost all the Native art
that you find either online or in stores
features fake Native American art when I
walk into a store and I see cultural art
from my community that's counterfeit it
feels like a family photo on a product
in a store it feels that personal to me
and I wanted to do something about it
[Music]
my name is Louie Gong I'm a nuke sack
tribal member and I'm the founder of
eighth generation which is based at Pike
Place Market in Seattle when I walk
through the mall
almost every store has native art on
products in it and not one of those
products is connected to a native
artists to me that represents a huge
problem and eight generation tries to
address that problem by creating actual
opportunities for cultural artists to
develop products I'm a self-taught
artist and about 10 years ago I started
doing art by customizing a pair of shoes
and I had developed a really strong
organic following from doing that work
we know that people want to buy native
art so that eventually became the
foundation of eighth-generation
[Music]
we have about 15 different business
relationships with makers within two
miles of Pike Place Market when you buy
products featuring
are done by native people and produced
by Native owned companies you're
strengthening the cultural art and the
communities whose artwork you like we're
the first Native owned company to offer
wool blankets this is important because
the aesthetic of wool blankets has
largely been native when people think of
wool blankets they think of Native art I
think people are used to seeing native
people in one of three categories
you know we're typically a charity
project or a symbol of history or a
symbol of the natural environment we're
planting a seed about who native people
really are and so when they walk in the
door the message that gets conveyed is
that we're alive and we're thriving and
that contradicts what people want to
think about native people this is indigo
real indigo jeans they're died from a
chemical but real indigo straight from
the plant has its roots in samurai
culture and it's highly prized in Japan
yep this story is all about the real
color blue but it's not as dull as it
sounds
[Music]
Tokushima Japan is located in the
southwest of the country
and for centuries it has been known for
its indigo due to the yoshinogawa River
which flows underground warming the soil
indigo started gaining popularity in the
early 1600s and was commonly used by
samurais so do I use a mystical thought
that you thought you Illuminati but it's
got a yo-yo missile
this is Osamu knee he's a sixth
generation indigo plant grower totally
stunning isn't it I don't really know so
you know minutes with it
mocchi hey guys that'll get them all
Keke's demo can I open say over wheel
indigo was also used for firefighters
clothing because it's flame-retardant up
to 1500 degrees Fahrenheit
to produce indigo ink the leaves must be
harvested and then dried in the Sun and
flipped repeatedly with a broom until
they turn a navy hue I have we eating it
cut a thin circle to send us there
because of this
Osamu is one of the last five in new
grow growers in the region the practice
is time-consuming and labor-intensive so
former growers have turned to cheaper
chemical alternatives but the thing is
with real indigo the color you can
achieve is unparalleled
this is Toshi haru furusho he's a fabric
tire Yaya
Sami cookies even given a calendar day
some attention what a mistake you know I
know he is able to pull out an
incredible range of blues from the
natural ink from a nearly black blue
they called nano arrow to deep ocean
Hughes called Cacharel achieving these
colors though is not easy
I don't know need talk over a Coca okay
Jo his commitment to his craft can be
seen in his hands his nails are
eternally stained blue from nearly 50
years of working with the die tomorrow
[Music]
a lot of us don't meet Amana what do you
know this man I know some oh he's not
hanging his trial yet up either yeah
buddy Isaac Oreo
sukhothai Coty you know Iman okay no ice
uh no Komachi is good you know
yes hi by number two guru do you see
current reading
[Music]
when you put on a hat it gives you
height and it gives you power for us
church hats are not just passed they are
crowns and when a woman puts one on she
becomes a queen my name is Iveta petty
I'm Kathy Anderson and I am one chambers
we've been making hats for more than 20
years a church hat is a very special hat
especially in the african-american
community as a child growing up in the
South in the 60s we always wore hats
sunday is the one day historically that
we had a chance and we step out in our
Sunday - I don't believe that church
hats are a thing of the past
[Music]
I have noticed that the younger
generation is taking on the tradition of
weird hats it makes me happy to see a
younger woman with a hat on her head
because I know that she's still carrying
on the tradition
I come from a long line of church
hat-wearing women everyone war had it
was a parade
it was colors it was magic
when you go to church and you step in
and you see all of your sisters wear
hats on we all be eyeing each other
and under our brushing or that's a
really gorgeous hat so it's wonderful to
be in a room filled with women with hats
on and each one of us look absolutely
amazing in our own right as a tradition
of tower of to violets is gonna need to
do puja one is next photograph was
developed with the greatest in town and
I registered suppose a bogus bogus
tradition and says go be punished
[Music]
cousins disbeliever is some grad program
focused to DJ drama Bulgaria culture
every bit the way that's private Nagisa
mr. fan not a good you know Bulgaria
this govern was it a Duke evasive and
missus today with a garment electronics
and so me as well the prepositional
around regulation and so proposed with
master grouper for him as a cookies kiss
with federal customer it's not revenue
morale booster
original private the present in intell's
the Java so additional national priority
non-english juntos para process or
glacial Tunis Amato Javad McCoy -
especially with product culture the soul
gracious the dosa question
[Music]
to vanish to demo reality no patches
panini automata sir Watkyn of human
settlement services including in the
investor not particularly in the best
educational Ravi no cigar poverty to
nutritive of cookiecutter festival
director suffered no damage to horrid
statistician was sustained iam while
certain to know you must expect mr.
cotton internal emotional baggage amount
to Matamata boggling authority to
declare a physicist a neo-nazi tunic as
a curvature there's a strata nominal
tomato see he to fight ready to Susanna
Moyer awesomest go it was gulam moonda
vote EHS a producer
you
[Music]